As you asked earlier,
what did he give away to get it?
Listen to how Matt Gates described
what the House is going to be like,
perhaps under these new rules
that under the deal
that Kevin McCarthy landed with them,
the construct
of these rules, concessions.
Functionally term
the speakership
into a ceremony Hill position.
Matter of fact,
if my colleagues get what they want
from McCarthy,
the chairman of the Freedom Caucus
will actually be more important
than the speaker of the House.
He will have to live the entirety
in the speakership in a straitjacket
constructed by these rules
that we're working on now.
I mean, wow.
Is he right?
I mean, he's not wrong there.
And
speaking to those concessions,
I mean, what really makes Kevin McCarthy
so much less powerful
than other speakers in in the past
is that right now
he has a conference,
a very narrow majority
with many members
who are willing to just basically
push a vote
of no confidence on him at any turn,
any sort of bad move that
Kevin McCarthy
or that Speaker
Kevin McCarthy makes,
whether it's policy,
House rules, procedure,
tactics, politics,
as we saw earlier
this week as well, is going to be put
is going to put him in that position
of being put up for a referendum
because of that motion
to vacate a measure
where any one member can call
for that vote to speaker.
So we could see this
exercise over and over again.
And I imagine Kevin McCarthy,
while he is a fighter,
he is a survivor, he's
going to have to be
looking over his shoulder
almost every morning
when he wakes up to to figure out
how could I be ousted like today
and that
and that man, Matt Gaetz,
who you just saw on
your screen is going to be the person
trying to be front and center
on all of this.
How do you expect to govern this way
if it has been taking this long
to get the conference? You see?
This is a great part
because it took this long.
Now we learned how to govern.
So now we'll be able to get the job done.
Now we've learned how to.
Now we learned how hard it's going to be.
You get all of this done.
I am fascinated by this prize,
but tomorrow
we're going to be talking about rules
and the rules
are critically important here.
And this is not a fight that is over.
No, it's not a fight over.
There's two things
or a couple of things happening.
They're going to vote on the actual rules
package tomorrow.
That's going to pass
There's only one member
who's oppose a Republican
who's opposed Tony Gonzales of Texas.
That's going to pass.
But the thing we haven't seen,
there's a document circulating around
with a couple of pages,
like a three page document
that cut some unwritten rules
that they're talking about,
which is like reducing spending to
to 20, 22 levels.
Which would be big cuts
in government spending.
And this was one of the problems
that McCarthy face is
moderates were upset about.
So this is like not in the rules package,
but it's like a secret document
that's floating around, floating around,
and they're not actually even
letting people have copies. So,
yeah, how damaging it would be to them
if it got out Yeah.
And so,
I mean, there's going to be
where they're going to
they're going to try and pass
the rules package.
They'll get that done
and then they're going
to launch into some votes, too.
They think that that will help them.
There'll be a version votes,
there'll be a crime vote.
But, you know,
we're going to see a fight
pretty soon on immigration.
That's going to happen in the House.
And that's going to be
the first flashpoint
and I think he's going to have a problem
because they have a problem.
As you pointed out,
some of the concessions
that we are learning
that McCarthy made
include this idea that they can cap
spending at fiscal year.
22 levels,
which would be a cut to defense spending.
There is the motion to vacate,
which would allow anyone to call a vote
to get rid of the speaker at any moment.
Basically,
putting some of these hard
liners on key committees, etc., etc.
I mean, no more omnibus spending deals.
These are
potentially pretty
significant concessions
which really raise the question
about what is going to happen
to the institution
over the next two years.
Well, you played that clip of Gates
calling this a straitjacket.
So that list is really the straitjacket
that he's trying to describe.
Basically,
it ties the hands in
some of these critically,
potentially crisis level
situations of the leadership
to try and solve problems fast.
Which is what
honestly omnibus
spending bills have become
in recent years.
That's not to say it's not a problem.
Congress is not supposed
to govern this way.
In fact,
I think there's
one of the youngest members
of Congress,
the first time since Congress
passed all of its appropriations
bills on time was the year
he was born or the year before you write
something like that. Right.
So this is how we've we've operated for
a long time.
But, you know,
I think that
the we've learned
how to govern sticks in my head
because, you know,
this has been the reality
inside the Republican conference
since well before
Kevin McCarthy got the gavel. Right.
This was why John Boehner resigned.
This is ultimately why
Paul Ryan decided to throw in the towel.
This has been an ungovernable
act conference
this group of people have bedeviled
anyone who's actually tried
to run the country.
And this was a much more prolonged
version of I think
the example
that was set
That means we're going to be
going from crisis to crisis.
We're going to face
potentially a government shutdown.
When we hit the debt ceiling,
we potentially face
the very real possibility of a default.
It seems like a lot of these members
do not care about that.
And there are very real world
consequences.
And it's going to layer
right over the top of a very contentious
maybe. Maybe they don't.
Maybe they don't care.
Some of them actually want to take it
all the way to the brink.
And then on top of that,
there's something else
that McCarthy agreed to.
This is a committee
that would investigate
the investigators, investigate
the FBI and the DOJ,
people who,
by the way,
are investigating some of these
sitting members of Congress.
This is extraordinary.
It also would
it would
would kind of dabble
in some of this
sort of social media censorship world.
McCarthy pretty much immediately
said, yes, we're going to do that.
What is that going to do?
Well, we'll see what it does.
And they wanted funding
for that committee.
So, I mean, the reality is
that is
all that
will be playing out here
with many investigations.
The Hunter Biden
investigation is something that
really was,
you know,
one of the reasons
that Republicans are one.
I mean, there were every Republican voter
I talked to last year.
It was very concerned about this
and the Afghanistan pullout, China,
the the origins of a covert
there is some real oversight
and investigations here.
This investigating the investigators.
We'll see.
I mean, that is something that the
Jim Jordan and others wanted.
But at the
at the end of the day here, one thing
we're also not talking about,
we can forget
the Senate is controlled by Democrats
yeah. So never.
Never. And the White House for sure.
So never mind what gets out of the House.
I mean,
most of the stuff is dead on arrival.
So but one thing is different.
Some Democrats will be in
the House,
will vote for some of these things.
So that will be a margin a
you know, because
because help
for Kevin
McCarthy here
on the spending things and other things,
some moderate Democrats will help him.
Yeah.
I mean, look,
if you tell Democrats, let's cap defense
spending at lower level,
some of them will be like, sure,
we need to do that.
So that's one of the things.
But but
it strikes
me also
that the fallout from all of this is
that McCarthy
has basically singlehandedly empowered
these really fringe characters
in the Republican Party.
You're talking about people
like Paul Gosar and Scott Perry.
Paul Gosar,
who spoke
at a white supremacist
conference, Scott Perry,
who is basically being subpoenaed
over his involvement
in the January 6th stuff, Jim Jordan.
Marjorie Taylor
Greene is a member of leadership,
essentially describes herself now.
I mean,
that's really extraordinary
and may be a long
lasting consequence of all of this.
Right. Right.
Because of the narrow majority
that House Republicans won in November.
He is so Kevin McCarthy is so hamstrung
by these very, very
I mean, it's
hard to call them conservative.
They're just very hard
line far right people
and a very, very small minority
of the conference
where most of the conference
or a majority of the conference
do want to actually unify, govern
and get some stuff done.
And get some of the red meat stuff
out there.
But I am just a
when when when Jeff was talking,
I was thinking about what
speaker former Speaker John
Boehner used to say back
when he was in charge.
He would try to temper expectations
against a Democratic Senate
and a Democratic White House
back, that
he said we control
what was at
one half of one third of government
to try to illustrate
how little
they could actually get accomplished
because of the opposition in the Senate
and the White House.
How is Speaker
McCarthy going to temper
those expectations?
Against these?
House
Republicans have set a pretty
high bar for him.
I mean, one dynamic to watch.
Yeah,
they're not going to be
unilaterally passing any spending bills
or dealing with the debt ceiling.
They have to deal with the other half of
two thirds right now, one.